Landing a role in a Marvel movie means potential
stardom for up-and-coming actors, renewed
popularity for aging vets, and a fat paycheck
for anyone willing to don a cool metal suit.
But despite Marvel's impact on the modern
movie business, not every actor is keen to
put on a mask and do battle with alien armies.
Here are a few actors who refused big Marvel
roles.
Russell Crowe
These days, Marvel movies are guaranteed to
bring in big numbers at the box office, but
before the year 2000, that wasn't necessarily
the case.
Fortunately, things started to change for
Marvel when Bryan Singer's X-Men first hit
the bigscreen.
It's credited as the film that gave rise to
the modern era of superhero movies, and transformed
Hugh Jackman from a stage performer into a
Hollywood A-lister.
But according to the actor, it was pure luck
he got the part in the first place.
At one point, the filmmakers turned to Russell
Crowe to play Wolverine, who was fresh off
the
set of Gladiator.
However, Crowe turned the part down for a
reason that's, well, a little weird.
"I'd just done a character whose animal totem
was a wolf, ya know, which was that fellow
Max in Gladiator.
So I didn't want to be connected with a wolf
again."
Of course, Crowe further clarified his reasoning…
"and plus it's a cartoon,"
"It was a cartoon"
"and I'm not really into those."
But that didn't really stop him from appearing
in Man of Steel.
Luckily for superhero fans everywhere, he
did recommend that Bryan Singer go with Hugh
Jackman, who'd previously auditioned for the
part.
Matt Damon
As hard as we try, no one can forget 2003's
Daredevil.
While the Ben Affleck flick did well financially,
critics tore it apart.
When asked about the film in 2016, Affleck
responded,
"I hated Daredevil so much, you know what
i mean.
I did ok, don't feel bad for me."
Turns out that Affleck could've been spared
all that embarrassment if his best friend
had accepted the role first.
Matt Damon was offered the part of Daredevil,
and it was a pretty tempting deal, since Damon
and Affleck considered Daredevil to be their
favorite superhero.
But when Damon was approached with the project,
reportedly he just wasn't impressed with the
script or familiar enough with the director.
Affleck couldn't say no, and has come to regret
that decision.
But at least Daredevil's failure inspired
him to get his next superhero movie "right."
Joseph Gordon-Levitt
Over the years, there have been a lot of whispers
about Joseph Gordon-Levitt and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, but JGL has denied them
all, from Doctor Strange to Ant-Man.
Nevertheless, according to Deadline, the actor
was in the running for the role of Peter Quill,
a.k.a. Star-Lord, which he allegedly turned
down to play the character of Johnny in Sin
City: A Dame to Kill For.
Which probably wasn't a great choice for Gordon-Levitt,
but we're pretty happy with Chris Pratt.
Olivia Munn
When Deadpool hit theaters in early 2016,
moviegoers went wild for the film's raunchy
humor and bloody shootouts.
X-Men: Apocalypse, on the other hand, wasn't
quite so successful, limping away from theaters
with a Rotten Tomatoes score of 48 percent.
But none of these numbers really mattered
to Olivia Munn.
Before signing up to play the role of Psylocke
in X-Men, Munn was first offered the role
of Vanessa Carlysle, Deadpool's "scrappy"
girlfriend.
Munn turned the part down in favor of playing
the spandex-clad mutant, saying that she wasn't
interested in playing the protagonist's "eye
candy."
Instead, she wanted to be a character with
"powerful abilities", extreme fighting skills…
and a costume that's pretty much underpants.
Mel Gibson
It was a coup for Marvel's movies when award-winner
Anthony Hopkins agreed to join the MCU as
Odin, Thor's father and king of Asgard.
While he seems like an obvious pick for the
role, he wasn't the only actor in the running
for the Allfather.
In an interview with The Guardian, Mel Gibson
explained that he was asked to play Odin,
but, as he succinctly put it, "I didn't do
it."
At first glance, the action star seems an
odd pick to play the stately Norse god, but
with a solid background in Shakespearean theater,
Gibson probably would've felt comfortable
with Odin's aristocratic dialogue.
Of course, with all the controversy surrounding
the actor, it was probably best for the MCU
that Gibson turned down the part.
Jessica Chastain
Iron Man 3 was the second highest-grossing
domestic movie of 2013, and its praise and
profit isn't undeserved.
Audiences enjoyed witty dialogue, a brilliant
plot twist, and one of the greatest ending
set-pieces in Marvel movie history.
The only thing it really lacked was Jessica
Chastain.
The studio wanted Chastain to play the part
of Maya Hansen, a scientist who may or may
not be on Tony Stark's side.
Unfortunately, Chastain had to pass on the
role because she was just too busy.
She said to her Facebook fans,
"I know many of you want me to be involved,
and I'm sorry to disappoint you.
Hopefully there'll be another Marvel film
in my future."
Of course, it isn't like Chastain's decision
hurt her career.
After she turned down the role, it went to
Rebecca Hall.
Originally, Maya Hansen was supposed to be
the ultimate villain of the film, but someone
up the chain of command ordered writer-director
Shane Black to make the bad guy a dude…because
female action figures supposedly don't sell
that well, leaving Hall in a much less important
role than anticipated.
Joaquin Phoenix
When Marvel Studios was preparing to introduce
audiences to Doctor Stephen Strange, there
were a few names at the top of their list.
They were allegedly interested in the likes
of Jared Leto and Ryan Gosling, but it seems
Joaquin Phoenix came even closer to landing
the gig.
The Oscar-nominated star ultimately decided
to pass on the Sorcerer Supreme because he
didn't feel he would do well in a studio full
of green screens, and the role went to Benedict
Cumberbatch.
However, there was a brief bit of time where
it seemed Cumberbatch wouldn't be able to
wear the Cloak of Levitation, as he was already
signed up to play Hamlet in a London stage
production.
To accommodate Cumberbatch's schedule, the
studio ended up pushing back Doctor Strange's
release date.
Emily Blunt
Marvel realized Emily Blunt's action star
potential long before the rest of us.
As Kevin Feige and Jon Favreau prepared to
shoot Iron Man 2, they offered the English
actress one of the biggest roles in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe: Natasha Romanoff, a.k.a.
Black Widow.
Unfortunately for Blunt, the timing just didn't
work out.
She was busy with the Jack Black comedy Gulliver's
Travels and had to pass on playing the Russian
super spy.
Which was a pretty huge mistake.
Marvel still really wanted Blunt to join the
MCU, so when it came time to film Captain
America: The First Avenger, execs asked if
she'd be interested in playing Steve Rogers's
capable love interest, Peggy Carter.
Once again, the timing was off, and the part
went to Hayley Atwell.
In a 2012 interview with Vulture, Blunt admitted
that she's still open to a superhero role,
as long as she gets to play a hero, saying,
"Usually, the female parts in a superhero
film feel thankless: She's the pill girlfriend
while the guys are whizzing around saving
the world."
Matthew McConaughey
If you've seen Guardians of the Galaxy, it's
easy to see why people are incredibly psyched
for its sci-fi sequel, and it seems like any
actor in Hollywood would gladly sign up for
a trip to Xandar.
For example, both Sylvester Stallone and Kurt
Russell will appear alongside Chris Pratt,
but despite all the excitement, not every
actor is willing to soar off into space with
Star-Lord.
In an interview with Playboy, Oscar-winner
Matthew McConaughey said he was offered a
role in Vol. 2 but turned it down to appear
in adaptation of Stephen King's The Dark Tower,
saying,
"I like Guardians of the Galaxy, but what
I saw was, 'It's successful, and now we've
got room to make a colorful part for another
big-name actor.'
I'd feel like an amendment."
McConaughey didn't say which part he was offered
in Vol. 2, though most agree he would've played
a villain.
Still, the Guardians sequel should be plenty
of fun even without McConaughey in the film…though
it'd be a lot cooler if he'd signed up.
"Action and there's the chick, alright alright
alright"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!